Well, this one is not so bad. The answer is 40° and let's look at why.
Well, here comes the sun's rays, arriving in parallel all over the surface of the earth.
These lines are supposed to be parallel. Well, let's replace our little guy with just a vertical object.
Well, check it out-as our rays drawing in some parallel lines has really helped us solve this problem
because look at what we have here--our angle α which by definition--that's the longitude--
that's how we define longitude and that's exactly equal to this angle here,
which we also happen to call α there, but hey, good coincidence they're the exact same angle.
And so if we measure this angle to be 40°, this must also be 40°.
We'll see things change a little bit.
If it's not on the equinox, it gets a bit more tricky but I think you can handle that
and you'll do that in the premise that at the end of this unit.